como investigadora social y gestora
cultural yo me ocupo de la ciudad su
historia y sus imágenes sin embargo no
me detengo en la historia oficial la
historia de los grandes personajes de
los hechos trascendentes de las
cronologías tampoco en las imágenes
icónicas de ciudad aquellas que nos
permiten imaginar la ciudad como una
postal que aún sin conocer la podamos
experimentarla
mi mirada es más bien antropológica me
ocupo de las pequeñas historias y las
imágenes que ustedes que yo que nosotros
los ciudadanos producimos en nuestra
vida cotidiana
nosotros los hacedores de ciudad para
investigar la ciudad es una tarea muy
compleja porque se nos presenta como un
laberinto de significados con múltiples
identidades capas de historia yo pienso
que es como un mapa que una vez que uno
lo cree capturado dibujado se desdibuja
y entonces a los investigadores no nos
queda sino entrar a través de ciertos
espacios momentos o fragmentos y el
espacio a través del cual imagino
algunas ciudades en latinoamérica y en
particular la ciudad de quito es este su
centro histórico
una brevísima captura en la primera
imagen
debemos saber todo reconocido una ciudad
emplazada en una montaña o no esta
ciudad una ciudad andina pero con una
geografía particular y con un trazado en
cuadrícula el damero fundacional de las
ciudades coloniales en la segunda imagen
seguramente reconocieron todos una plaza
mayor el lugar emblemático del poder en
la colonia de la república pero también
el lugar emblemático de la protesta y de
la lucha social en américa latina y en
la tercera imagen un teatro este teatro
y esta plaza en la que estamos hoy
teatro nacional sucre cuyo nombre dicen
se debe a una joven política que hace
más de 130 años imagino un escenario
lírico para pensar los modernos
ahora yo les diría
en estas imágenes reconocieron a la
gente que estaba en ellas me pueden
decir que así en esas personas quienes
eran es probable que no hayan reparado
en ellas yo me pregunto si las historias
de estas personas no son dignas de
entrar en las grandes historias de la
ciudad
quito- fue imaginada como un monumento
como un tesoro a proteger como una
reliquia arquitectónica por los
hispanistas de inicios del siglo 20
ellos quisieron proyectar a la ciudad y
diferencia de la de otras ciudades de
américa latina' dale un lugar en el
mundo por ese reconocimiento llega
recién hacia el año de 1978
cuando la organización de naciones
unidas para la ciencia la educación y la
cultura la unesco declara quitó como la
primera ciudad patrimonio mundial junto
con cracovia en realidad las dos
ciudades
inauguran la lista de ciudades
patrimoniales esta lista se engrosará
con las décadas y está hoy por hoy
integrada por gran parte de las ciudades
monumentales del mundo y obviamente por
los centros históricos de américa
latina'
ahora
volviendo a esta pregunta me preguntaba
yo que se había dicho sobre las ciudades
los centros históricos cuando estas
declaratorias tomaron posición se nos
había contado que estas ciudades tenían
un extraordinario valor arquitectónico
un valor de arquitectura civil y
religiosa un valor artístico estético
monumental y que por tanto eran dignas
de ser conservadas pero también se nos
había contado un relato sobre su gente
se nos dijo que las personas que
evitaban los centros históricos los
abandonaron a principios del siglo 20
pero hasta entrada a la mitad del siglo
20 probablemente en la mayoría de
centros históricos latinoamericanos y el
relato quedó ahí no se nos dijo más se
nos dijo que se fueron también las
élites se fueron de acuerdo pero el
relato no cierra qué pasó después
quiénes fueron esos cientos de miles de
personas que han habitado los centros
históricos latinoamericanos desde esa
salida de las élites a mediados del
siglo 20 hasta hoy
me pregunto también si sus memorias otra
vez no son dignas de ocupar un lugar en
la gran historia de nuestras ciudades y
quiero contarles una breve historia ella
es marta una mujer que en los años
sesentas llega a la ciudad de quito
campesina con 17 años la ilusión del
progreso que ofrece la ciudad de capital
poquísimos recursos un marido
se ubica en un barrio que da la
bienvenida a los migrantes en la ciudad
de quito en esa época llamado el barrio
de la ronda alquila un pequeño
dormitorio en una casa de inquilinato y
arranca su vida con su oficio como
costurera y una década después en los
años 70 la ciudad se expandía al ritmo
del boom petrolero como nunca antes las
periferias eran ocupadas por esta ciudad
que se alargaba en ese entonces marta ya
había dejado de habitar su dormitorio a
pasta y pasó a un departamento de tres
habitaciones en una casa de inquilinato
compartida por otras 20 familias todas
migrantes esa era la ciudad entonces
diez años después de hacia los años 80
la clase media se expandía pero la
ciudad dejó de mirar a su centro
histórico los vecinos de este barrio
marta y sus vecinos empezaron a pensar
que quizás al estado no le preocupaba
tanto su realidad la inseguridad abatía
a los barrios eran cada vez más
inaudibles invisibles frente a las
autoridades ahora
cambió drásticamente este escenario en
el año de 1987 cuando un terremoto
sacude a la ciudad de quito se encienden
las alarmas sobre la fragilidad del
patrimonio monumental civil y religioso
de esta ciudad y se empiezan a hacer
leyes se dan financiamiento se crean
instituciones desde entonces hasta hoy
más de 400 millones de dólares han sido
invertidos en este lugar el centro
histórico de quito con esa gran gesta de
recuperación del centro histórico se
imprime un nuevo relato sobre sus
habitantes se nos dice que son
habitantes de tugurios que viven
hacinados que son pobres son los medios
nos reiteran imágenes miserabilista
sobre la población del centro histórico
de quito
y ahora
los vecinos como marta empiezan a sentir
fuertemente este proceso de
estigmatización habitar ciertos barrios
como la ronda era un motivo para que se
les negara a crédito empiezan a perder
oportunidades de empleo menos gente
llega al barrio empiezan a salir algunos
vecinos es una situación dramática para
las familias del barrio y el barrio acá
en completo abandono organizados buscan
ser audibles frente a las autoridades
sin respuesta
todo cambia con el cambio de siglo y la
gran crisis que vivió el ecuador a
propósito que nos llevó a la
dolarización en ese momento
y los vecinos empiezan a sentir
esperanza un gran proyecto se imprime
sobre el barrio la recuperación urbano
arquitectónica del barrio hasta ahí todo
bien
marta y sus vecinos salen de sus casas
de sus habitaciones de sus departamentos
en casas colectivas hasta esperar que
las casas fueran rehabilitadas y volver
a ellas nunca imaginaron que esto no
ocurriría de hecho no ocurrió
les ganaron los bares los restaurantes
los karaokes las tiendas de artesanía
cerraron los últimos locales del barrio
salieron los últimos vecinos en los
alrededores los vendedores ambulantes
eran expulsados del espacio público
un barrio quiteño en el 2006 se había
transformado en una calle turística
probablemente visitada por todos ustedes
una calle iluminada de noche muy activa
y muy viva y vacía de día casi 100
habitantes el relato oficial se empieza
a imprimir sobre el barro y nos empiezan
a hablar otra vez de sus habitantes pero
sus habitantes no eran marta y los
vecinos eran los poetas los músicos de
inicios del siglo 20
marta es una ficción pero al mismo
tiempo es una realidad mata sintetiza la
historia de cientos de miles de
habitantes de los centros históricos
latinoamericanos desplazados por un
proceso llamado gentrificación un
proceso que se da en fases
abandono estigmatización especulación
regeneración especulación desplazamiento
de exposición mercantilización y también
resistencia científica ción es un
anglicismo una muy mala traducción
podría ser elitización del espacio
urbano qué quiere decir esto que en el
capitalismo avanzado y en el proceso de
organización planetaria ustedes saben
que la mayor cantidad de personas del
planeta habitan ciudades se producen
ciertos inversiones en espacios que son
considerados o que han sido reiterados
como espacios degradados degenerados
entre comidas estos espacios reciben
inversiones públicas y privadas pueden
ser puertos plazas barrios calles
barrios pintorescos incluso pueblos
rurales o zonas naturales con estas
inversiones se busca atraer a la
industria inmobiliaria turística
cultural recreativa y varias otras se
atraen también nuevos habitantes los
gentrificación es estos habitantes
llegan y desplazan por efecto de su
capacidad adquisitiva y su capacidad de
consumo a los anteriores de habitantes
la gentrificación en muchas muchas de
las ciudades del mundo desplaza a los
habitantes originales de esos espacios
en ese momento que son por lo general
inmigrantes poblaciones indígenas
poblaciones de afro campesinos pobres de
la ciudad
la identificación producción la ciudad
expulsó ahora una ciudad para pocos
hoy se ejemplifica por ejemplo portland
which brooklyn lisboa a venecia brixton
marcela barcelona-madrid el barrio de la
merced en el centro histórico de méxico
los ángeles melbourne beijing van gogh
en fin buena parte de los centros
históricos latinoamericanos estos
procesos han sido seriamente
documentados por cineastas por
investigadores por los medios
progresistas de entre comillas sin
embargo yo me pregunto por qué estas
historias que afectan a millones de
personas en todo el mundo nos llegan a
la tapa del periódico porque no son la
primera plana porque no estamos
discutiendo lo que está ocurriendo hoy
en este momento en este lugar porque se
hacen generalmente en nombre de un bien
mayor de aquello que la sociedad
considera algo positivo para todos entre
comillas para todos ahora quién podría
resistirse por ejemplo a transformar un
lugar que nos ha sido dicho que es un
lugar degradado en función de criterios
como la cultura la naturaleza el
patrimonio el arte el espacio público o
un metro que va a resolver los problemas
de movilidad de todos nosotros
son discursos purificadores son
discursos que esconden finalmente
sacralizan lo que tocan
pero ha sido como hay centrifugación y
como la gentrificación es un proceso
global y expansivo también lo es el
proceso de resistencia de los habitantes
de las ciudades a escala global la
capacidad humana de organizarse de
luchar de resistir de reclamar un
derecho a la ciudad también es
inagotable se hacen ver y oír por
ejemplo en el barrio de san telmo en
buenos aires- los vecinos en contra de
los arrendamientos temporarios buscan
defender el mercado de san telmo que
muchos de ustedes conocerán de su de su
desaparición como ya desapareció el
mercado del barrio del abasto para dar
paso a un shopping
están alertas los vecinos no quieren que
sea un barrio de paseantes lleno de
arrendamientos temporarios resisten y
luchan también reclaman la ciudad se
hacen ver y oír los las poblaciones
indígenas del mercado de sant roc en
quito ustedes saben que buena parte de
sus alimentos vienen de este en este
barrio están en resistencia en contra
del cierre y desplazamiento del mercado
busquen incorporar sus saberes y sus
prácticas indígenas y un espacio
intercultural dentro del gran patrimonio
de la ciudad resisten y se hacen ver se
hacen oír los vecinos y vecinas del
barrio de san marcos en quito con
quienes hemos trabajado procesos de
recuperación de memoria y de imagen
desde los álbumes familiares ellos han
puesto unas baldosas que se resisten al
olvido en las fachadas de sus casas para
que nosotros los paseantes cuando
vayamos por ese barrio veamos y digamos
bueno aquí hay gente tras la fachada hay
habitantes hay vida y una vida en
comunidad con su puño y letra' con su
grafía fotografías de las familias
dicen aquí estamos reclaman además la
vida barrial como un patrimonio cultural
se hacen ver y resisten los desplazados
del barrio de la ronda en el centro
histórico de quito con quienes
trabajamos una exposición en el museo de
la ciudad en el año 2012
llevamos sus memorias traumáticas las
memorias del dolor de haber perdido su
comunidad pero también les llevamos a la
ciudadanía una pregunta a los políticos
y planificadores si es posible pensar
procesos de renovación urbana de otra
manera desde la inclusión de los
ciudadanos con la participación de los
ciudadanos y buscar junto a la
ciudadanía que visitó la exposición
alternativas compartidas frente a este
proceso de desplazamiento de habitantes
se hacen ver y escuchar también cientos
de vecinos con los que hemos trabajado
en el centro histórico de quito a lo
largo de los de la última década
mediante documentales participativos de
exposiciones en el espacio público
trabajos de fotografía libros textos
ellos ponen a circular sus memorias y
sus historias y dicen aquí estamos aquí
estamos el centro histórico
es un monumento por cierto iluminado
maravilloso pero como todo monumento es
luz y sombra ilumina esta ciudad
extraordinaria pero también esconde y
oscurece la vida cotidiana de cientos de
personas
en el año 1990 habitaban en el centro
histórico de quito 60.000 personas hoy
estamos al 2018 habitamos 40.000
personas cada día somos menos personas
habitando este espacio
ahora es una historia dramática no es
cierto pero es posible evitar la que
podemos hacer para evitar estos procesos
se puede al menos frenar la
hay ciudades que están inventando
estrategias maravillosas para poder
hacer frente a este problema quiénes
están por ejemplo se debate en la ciudad
de barcelona cómo hacer grandes
proyectos de vivienda de contenido
social en otras ciudades se debate la
vivienda interclasista se regulan los
arrendamientos temporarios se crean
cooperativas de vivienda se produce en
desarrollos mixtos se generan planes de
empleo local para un turismo responsable
en que participa los habitantes y los
posibles desplazados de estos espacios
se incorporan los patrimonios y los
saberes también en las políticas
públicas y se producen también
legislaciones anti gentrificación que
permitan parar el desplazamiento de
personas en nuestras ciudades y
priorizar a las a los seres humanos a
las personas por sobre las inversiones
del capital
ahora para que todo esto sea posible se
necesita un primer gesto y el primer
gesto de es querer ver el texto que
proponen en el barrio de san marcos'
después de trascender la fachada la
fachada y el monumento iluminado y poder
ver que atrás de eso hay gente hay
personas como nosotros con vidas que
están amenazadas
sin embargo cada ciudad produce
gentrificación de manera distinta no es
del mismo proceso en cada ciudad la de
quito es particular la de las ciudades
andinas de es particular y se produce
con relación a procesos históricos de
nuestras formas de vernos racismos
clasismos que hacen una sociedad
compleja y para mirar esto estas estos
modos de ver y hacer ciudad en la ciudad
de quito quiero que me acompañen y
vayamos hace 100 años a este centro
histórico y miremos esta imagen
este domingo la so fue un fotógrafo
quiteño que creó un libro que se llama
quito a la vista en el año de 1911 lazo
era parte de unas mentalidades racistas
de la época y pensó que este álbum debía
mostrar un quitó oculto y moderno en sus
propias palabras y que para eso tenía
que eliminar ciertos aspectos de la
ciudad que la volvían fea también en sus
palabras
su estrategia fue borrar aquello que
considero un exceso
pero no solo borrarlo como en esta
imagen de la plaza grande hay unos
tachones pero también hay una
sustitución una mujer parisina vestida
de blanco una ciudad andina 2500 metros
donde usamos poncho
y en esta otra imagen de josé domingo
lazo aquí donde estamos en la plaza del
teatro también hay un sujeto que fue
borrado de la historia quiénes son estas
personas que no eran dignas de ser
mostradas quiénes eran esas personas de
excluidas del proyecto urbana moderno
unos años antes un fotógrafo extranjero
paul browser tomó esta imagen de la
misma plaza casi con la misma
perspectiva paul browser da cuenta de
una ciudad real de una ciudad andina
barroca de una vida popular vibrante
pero a diferencia del lazo por grosser
nos permitió ver a estas comunidades
históricamente invisibilizadas que han
habitado la ciudad a lo largo de la
historia que la habitan hoy y que hoy
resisten me pregunto si ahora
las vemos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]